hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about five healthy
habits for bloating and belly fat okay
so take note number one avoid grazing
what does that mean it means all the
snacking between the meals has to go why
because every time you eat you trigger a
hormone called insulin and insulin
creates inflammation in your colon okay
it just makes this thing swell up so
what you want to do is do three meals a
day
only and if you can even two meals a day
eventually because what will happen that
third meal will be your body eating the
belly fat okay because we want it to
burn fat and insulin is a switch if
insulin is low you won't have any
bloating at all in your stomach if
insulin is high
you'll feel bloated okay so avoid
grazing number two avoid certain veggies
now for me I can't eat broccoli I like
broccoli
but it bloats me so everyone's different
you might get bloated from kale you
might get bloated from cabbage so
whatever vegetable that bloats you avoid
it because even though it's healthy you
don't want anything to blow you okay
number three avoid grains and sugar now
this is the obvious one you probably
already know this but the gluten the
protein in grains called gluten will
really create inflammation in your colon
it's the number one source of IBS
irritable bowel syndrome diverticulitis
Crohn's and all these digestive issues
so you want to avoid that not to mention
the grains itself because grains turn
into sugar which increases you got it
insulin also sugar sugar creates a spike
in insulin that creates swelling of the
belly especially if you combine it with
protein or even fat so sugar is not good
at all and if you combine it you get a
worse effect okay so avoid grains and
all sugars number four avoid over eating
another obvious one but a lot of times
if you're just in a certain mode
especially at a restaurant you can just
really down some food
a social event you just keep eating and
eating and eating or watching TV and you
keep eating and eating eating so I
recommend that you really be conscious
about what you're eating and don't stuff
yourself because it's going to take a
long time to digest that food okay
number five eating when you are not
hungry there's this whole philosophy
that you have to always eat a breakfast
and I used to be the guy pushing that or
you have to eat through the day six
small meals even if you're not hungry
because it'll stimulate your metabolism
no no no no no when you're not hungry
do not eat why because your body is
burning fat if you add food the food is
probably not digested from the last meal
it's going to sit there and won't cause
more bloating so only eat when you are
hungry okay so I hope this helped go
ahead and apply this and give me some
comments below